une souris verte
texte christelle minier photographie
paille genre dans che moka édition une
souris grise mais non elle n'est pas
grise la souris elle est verte
une souris verte cachés dans les cannes
pas du tout c'est pas dans les cannes
allez on recommence une souris verte qui
courait dans l'herbe
je la tra par les moustaches n'importe
quoi
je l'attrapé par là que je la montre à
ces messieurs ces messieurs me disent
manger l'a bien vite allons burke ces
messieurs me dise tremper la dent lui le
tremper la dans l'eau ça fera un gros
dodo tout chaud oulala il est temps que
ça se termine ça fera un escargot touche
au bras vous